[Music]
we do have a guest uh joining us today
uh formerly of uh Tim cast IRL now uh
host of the Crigler show uh the very
widely uh liked and beloved Adam Crigler
joining us what's up man what's going on
guys how you doing I I just want to
establish real quick a couple ground
rules here okay all right Royce and I do
not like when people appear smarter than
us or funnier than us and I'm just just
letting you know but you outshine Us in
any way shape or form you're out of here
and we will never explain where you went
okay as long as we're clear I'm used to
it so all right as long as we're you're
great man I I actually the first time I
think we'll do Chrissy Mars uh like
500th episode thing is where I met you
and you're great man I mean I I've
checked out a lot of your stuff
um and uh dude your show is like [ __ ]
wonderful top tier and there's like no
smugness it's such a refreshing like
change you know thank you thank you but
I appreciate that it's nice to have
somebody in the sphere it's not a
complete like knee-jerk like so let's
just have the like the most knee-jerk
reaction to something immediately ever
it's nice to have somebody calmly go
let's calm down let's let's do this
calmly I was raised on logic and I tend
to to follow that before anything else
as much as I I possibly can yeah I mean
it's it is a big William of Arkham guy
William awakum okay well I don't even
know what that is I'm too stupid
um I'm really too dumb I don't know what
it is either so I guess
razor yeah there you go
if you say so uh that a shave brand is
that a plug that we have to do Occam's
razor guys one dollar a month to get
Occam's razors last night actually I
used Occam's razor that would be
hilarious Occam's razors one Buck a
month and we ship the razors right to
you I actually really love this it's
really stoic quotes like you know like
fortune cookie right so um obviously we
were we're talking about this a little
bit on Twitter but at least I was and um
you were you were just like that that
was a shock because I don't know you
don't have a Twitter you got banned I do
and it sucks right
um now who's the smartest guy in the
room stupid
um we uh no but uh we were talking about
this and you you were you were a a I
think like us an early Trump supporter
right like we were early like into the
Trump thing we're like this guy's
different
um no I can't say that when did you get
into him well I was not political at all
my most of my adult life I was just
living life doing my own thing and in
2020
once I joined the show on Tim Tim's
Channel
I just
was kind of forced to pay attention to
what I was listening you know what was
going on in the political landscape and
I just as I said I follow logic and I
actually did a deep dive on Trump so I I
started looking into his policies I
started looking into you know his
business career and I was like oh wow he
actually is a pretty good president and
I I you know it's hard to
it's hard to say otherwise unless you're
not really looking and
um I watched the DNC the joke of a
of a contest to decide for them to pick
the worst two candidates that that they
had on stage and they Iced Out Bernie
and they just iced them out twice yeah
of course of course they did because
they just want him to pull a certain you
know demographic into their fold and he
just done that multiple times now he'll
probably do it again I heard a rumor
that he's running again in 2024 it's
like uh yeah good job Bernie you learned
nothing did you I remember I actually
called it first too and [ __ ] even
Royce didn't believe me when we watched
those debates and I was watching it and
I went
Biden's going to get nominated and Royce
looks crazy looked at me and went no I I
said that [ __ ] way and I'm like it's
just just it's just she's the only one
they got I was looking at this [ __ ]
circus act freak Show and I'm like
they're not gonna run gamala no [ __ ]
way it's gonna make they're gonna make
Hillary look like a goddamn no but they
did they did but they didn't you
couldn't have her no you're right Ron
because she's just less likable Hillary
and I was watching it I'm like
God damn it they're going to run by and
invoice just like how how and I'm like I
don't know I didn't believe it
I think I lost a bet I made a bet at
like a five dollars and then I even was
the first one to go he's going to be
president I can feel that and
everybody's like no [ __ ] I'm like I just
got a bad feeling
hmm you know it kind of makes sense
though because you look at who they they
weren't gonna pick Tulsi because
you know she's too centered they she
didn't fall in line I obviously look at
what she's doing now you know uh Pete
Buddha judge I feel like they
they were kind of like
putting him out there just to see how
the environment felt uh I don't think
that he was ever really an actual
candidate
you know and then he also felt like a
kid he felt like a kid on that stage you
know it felt like Little Pete like he
was like when I was like like if they
were gonna do one of those cartoons
about young politicians like you know
like little politician yeah he's just a
little Pete like he just came off like a
little kid
so when
for us we were early we we were early
Trump guys we literally put on the splc
hate watch list for going to one of his
uh rallies one of the more rallies was
it 2017 or 2018
2017 went to a more rally and of course
these people sees a joke now but back
then it kind of mattered a little bit
and and we we've defended him and I
think you know for us and we've said it
on the show he
really started losing me with the
vaccine stuff that for me is I put up
look I put up a Bolton because I was
also like look he's not experienced he's
going to make mistakes which happens to
all of us right like we don't know what
we're doing and you know Bolton and then
everybody you know they turn themselves
and listen we've always said and even
today even even though I
completely lost my support Trump did but
he had the entire system against him and
that was absolutely no president's ever
had that and I get it but I think it's
not so much for me because I even a
couple months ago even after the vaccine
then I said look I don't like the
vaccine stuff but if but if we once
again you know this coming election
against Biden I'll reluctantly vote for
him because I can't have more Biden but
then when I saw the Candace Owens
interview and then when I saw other
people and then he's like he still won't
walk back the vaccine I would rather
have somebody like you know people go
deschanics lockdown too and I'm like he
did it for like a month but he also
after that said man I messed up we
shouldn't have done that and I respect
people that make mistakes and do that
but he's still going like no the
vaccine's the best thing in the world
and that for me and of course the
pardons partying like you know pardoning
Wheezy and not Julian Assange right uh
really hit me the wrong way [ __ ] yeah
I'm with you on that one and and part of
what I've noticed about his uh his
presidency is he trusted all the wrong
people
right I mean and that showed and and the
narcissism is you know hey I voted for
the guy but man does that guy love
himself and love winning and
you know he he probably doesn't want to
admit that he was wrong although that's
the one and only thing he's got to do
right yeah operation warp speed yeah I
mean I I I have some things to say about
that but I personally know that YouTube
will ban you or give you a strike for
saying specific things about a certain
subject yeah
um so I'm sure we're in a grill on the
vaccines we'll just put it that way
um and and although I don't know it's
common knowledge now I mean what what
this is what I say this this is how I've
we've been handling it because we have
gotten I'm not kidding you probably
three medical misinformation strikes
just far enough apart we didn't lose a
YouTube channel hence why we that's why
we did the rumble thing where we just
we're going we talked to them we're
doing rumbles and we have to worry about
it because that felt really awkward to
get actual we weren't trying we can't
wait till December yeah December 1st
we're Rumble completely but but we oh
wow okay yeah which is great for uh you
know we're gonna still put Clips up kind
of like Rogan does with the Spotify
stuff we'll put Clips up on our YouTube
channel but it's going to be Rumble only
because
it was so it felt so horrible for a lot
of people to see actual doctors actual
medical experts say stuff about it and
you weren't doing it so this I will say
and I said this before NBC news on their
Twitter has reported that they are now
doing long-term studies on the effects
of myocarditis because of that because
of the vaccine that is exactly they're
emitting it now yeah I just read that
article earlier right so crazy I didn't
even care about the vax or the
propaganda surrounding it or whatever if
you're gonna get tricked that easily
into being a guinea pig then God bless
you I it was the mandates the mandates
is where I'm now now we're getting into
a get the get the [ __ ] off my property
type situation
now now we're getting to one of those
I'm having a birthday for my
six-year-old yeah
wait wait what is it but it wasn't even
like the it wasn't even like the vet
like um you know the the overwhelming
like with the jobs and [ __ ] but it was
literally going to people's homes and
being like how many people are here and
it was like the gestapo and it's like
having a birthday party for my
four-year-old dude like there's like
seven people here relaxed and there's
like no no warrant cops are just looking
around they're checking for masks it was
like okay dude this is where we get into
a weird I'm not I'm not happy and get
the [ __ ] off my property yeah World
economic Forum came out and stated that
it was a test
oh yeah you know to see who they can
basically manipulate into falling in
line and what what about the dryer one
that they did in 2019 and people ignore
that they did a dry one of this where
they had a fake pandemic thing you know
what would happen if we had one and all
the world leaders met and China was
there and everyone was hanging out and
and it's it's it's again it's one of
those things where like you know
we like Alex we've had Alex Jones on our
show a bunch of times and that's one of
those things we're like outside of him
like only nobody was talking about that
stuff and it I kind of feel like it gets
it gets blocked out on purpose and I
think what Trump would let me down with
Trump with the vaccine was
okay
remember remember when he mentioned the
vaccine at his own rally and people that
these are the mega fans that are there
we even booed him the Alabama rally yeah
right and I remember that and that to me
made me feel you know uncomfortable I
understand that he's not and for me what
you know for us we're from Florida right
so obviously we understand that we have
a little bit more love for DeSantis and
maybe people that are not from here I
get that like I understand we have a
bias when it comes to that but I try to
take a step back and go the Santa's
literally sued the Biden Administration
for the mass mandates on planes that
that lawsuit is wide mask or gone on
planes so it's to me it's it's just like
why did you have to take a shot at
DeSantis you're not taking a shot at
Crooked Hillary or [ __ ] Perpetual
loser [ __ ] you're taking a shot at
somebody who's the Republican with the
biggest numbers who everybody loves like
what are you yeah exactly yeah and I
ride for my dog you know and I have
experience with people who uh want all
the attention for themselves
so you know you you grow to recognize
that kind of uh feeling in people it's
like hey I voted for Trump but I'm I'm
not a republican right you know I'm I'm
not a Democrat I am someone who follows
the logic and votes for a person and
wants the best like meritocracy right
and I know there's no such thing as like
the perfect politician a lot of people
are like oh there's just one thing no I
can't support this person anymore right
um you know so when it comes to Trump
it's like all right I see the narcissism
I see you know how obsessed he is with
winning
um
that the vaccine is the perfect example
of that you know so hearing about him
this sanctimonious it's like oh wait
what because a couple rhinos have been
supporting DeSantis
um you know or or did DeSantis not do
enough after your house got raided from
the FBI and you know his State you know
so I could see I could see Trump
you know and who knows maybe he's got
some people in his ear like oh yeah he's
coming for your seat which maybe he is
Kushner you know I think it's coach
probably I think yeah kushner's Kushner
to me is poison I agree you know the
thing here's here's the stuff like and I
agree with you because you're if you la
the Kanye's a great example of of and
and I'm connecting this because okay
people are like oh Kanye is crazy but
the stuff he said about the kushners in
that Tucker interview that was real
things and people ignore that shady
behavior and and okay so he what you
start thinking what if they're doing the
same thing what if they're trying to do
the same thing to Trump that they did
with Kanye you know getting in his ear
you know do what I am going to help you
out I'm gonna hook you up I'm gonna run
my policies and I do think that that is
a bad habit that Trump has but for for
me it's like you said the
disanctimonious thing and then okay fine
you know he takes shots at people but
then to be like I know things about him
and his wife that his wife doesn't know
I'm like now you're you're now you're
personally dude listen since Stormy
Daniels I defended you you know like why
are you why are you doing this to
somebody who's
really never said a bad word and I will
agree with you that yes maybe rhinos are
supporting him but my argument's always
like okay and David Duke and David Duke
and the KKK endorse Trump that doesn't
matter like that you can't you can't
help who endorses you I I do like this
I've just been imagining now like that
he has his own now he has his own
version of trump and a beanie just going
out there going creepy Adam griggler
people that's right that's what we used
to call creepy Adam
thought you're taking his shots at me
you're like oh I'm live
oh [ __ ] Adam crinzler
there you go boom Adam Granger that's
clearly used to come around here you see
the wood kids comes from his last name
I don't know I don't know folks I don't
know Trump's I don't know it's always
great because Trump cider knows like his
they have the news has to say allegedly
where he makes him outlandish statement
he goes I don't know if it's true it's
like okay man is weak folks he doesn't
have a band and he doesn't skateboard
oh [ __ ] oh man hey look honestly you
could tell us is is it because all this
music sounds like green day because I
couldn't be around that either bro
oh boy wait not plays music no not Trump
sure Trump
yeah you're right
um because if it is that's fine
um but um because like if I started a
band right I haven't been in a band
since high school if I started a band
all of a sudden rice would at least take
me aside as a friend and go it's
terrible don't put any of this on the
internet just for the sake of our show
what if I have Offspring struck
are good enough friends we care enough
about each other that if one of us if he
started rapping or I started a band one
of us would file a legal injunction
against the other one and go absolutely
not on the grounds that it affects our
company
all right well one thing I noticed there
sure that you you said that you guys are
actually friends yes oh that yeah yeah
we've never said to the other one we
never said to the other one okay you're
not really my friend like who said first
off who if merch said that to me I go
what literally everything we've done has
been known for almost two decades I know
it's a weird time that's the old opian
gym just a little over a decade you
can't stretch it then that's not you
know do you know what they say it's not
a real friendship until 12 years
everyone knows that yeah I guess so that
just that just reminds me of the old
Opie and Jim thing though remember when
Jim was like what's bothering you no
we're not that close we're going to tell
you you guys were broadcasting for 20
years yeah and and you live in the same
building and I gotta say dude and this
is honestly just because we know the
analog because we do YouTube we know the
numbers way better numbers when you're
on there bro that's just my observation
outside of like the Alex Jones and stuff
obviously but yeah because I wasn't a
yes man but merch that's the thing with
our show merch and I argue all the time
because we're friends we're like we've
known like forever we argue all the time
we disagree all that we have blowout
fights and we had a blowout fight the
day after the election yeah oh yeah yeah
we came we both came in and uh [ __ ] mood
and it was just like after the 2020
election we came in and we fought for
like an hour to like where half the chat
was like dude the show is over I know he
came back and apologized and we both
admitted like yeah we're all in a room
we're in a bad mood today man like it
was you know it was just very snippier
it's just it's almost as if friends can
come back almost and yeah proving that
civil discourse is actually needed in
this day and age and we had the excuse
of election guys inspiring but it's but
it but I agree I agree with that like it
but you're right through like this I'd
rather watch people with different
opinions like I'd rather isn't even if I
disagree with someone I get bored if I
just watched you know [ __ ] Hannity
you know sucking Trump's dick for an
hour it's like okay I get it again
enormous Combs we all missed calls Combs
but not because I liked Combs but it's
just hearing other things is how people
come to different conclusions the
problem is all the you know the right
right Wingers and everybody's always
complaining left Wingers to a 10 Echo
chamber it's an echo chamber it's an
echo chamber then when you finally do
something you're like oh wow these guys
disagree and maybe maybe and you know
what usually happens people disagree
fans and listeners tend to like going
like hey I agree with I agree with this
guy on this thing and I agree a little
bit with this guy on this thing and
people don't have to fight but
it is weird because I at least me
personally I don't like listening to uh
to Tim sanctimonious folks
that's just my personal thing you know
his middle name Yeah Tim sanctimonious
boy I haven't tell anybody that no he
doesn't it's Tim has spool uh like Homer
J Simpson
um but uh but you know you know it's
just I don't know man I think a lot of
the times not just with but with
everybody like you see so many shows
come together and they fall apart and
then it's something else and it's
because of this and it's like dude don't
take [ __ ] too seriously sometimes it's
like I mean like I said emergency I've
screamed at each other and afterwards
been like all right man yeah sorry I
yelled I shouldn't have yelled but I
still disagree with you you idiot and
that's it and move on instead of like I
don't know blow an entire thing up and
burn it to the ground and be like I'm
the winner okay okay that's on you bro
but who gives a [ __ ] dude I can't switch
I can't switch co-hosts every two months
like Andy warsky you know I mean there's
too much instability and I can't restart
my life and Rebrand every three months
I'm doing video games now guys you ever
hear of this game Skyrim I love where
I'm at it's great what I'm doing and I I
have uh I have a show on Mondays called
base staff Mondays with an awesome group
of guys and I have a lot of people that
have followed me through my solo career
on YouTube and Rumble I I shout out to
rumble too because Rumble is awesome uh
I really do enjoy I'll cut my stream
halfway through and just continue on
Rumble and talk about
certain opinions that are not allowed
on YouTube we've done that you know it's
funny we've we've done we've done you
know what's happened to Oscars or Rumble
the cool thing about now we're gonna go
Rumble only after a bit and for us it's
I mean it was it was easy for us because
I know a lot of people like if you're
monetized on YouTube
um you're still you're still going to
make some money the thing is during that
whole remember that whole adpocalypse
thing that happened with Carlos Mazza
and he had that fight with Crowder and
then they just demonetized a bunch of
channels
um no okay it was a couple years ago
Carlos Mazza the guy from Vox you know
started saying that Crowder was
homophobic or something and then YouTube
completely panicked and demonetized a
bunch of conservatives shows notice of
you know the the adpocalypse right that
was that was three years ago July three
years ago they demonetized us and they
never remonetized this so that kills us
you know we're we're so we were relying
on patreon and we were relying on on on
all of that but once they do that they
effectively kill you so what's happened
to us when we're doing the show on
YouTube and Rumble sometimes it's not
that we have to shut it off you
typically just kick us off and we just
keep doing it on Rumble because at this
point we would get a suspension and then
we would do Rumble and then we would
like turn to each other and go that was
a fun week of shows let's just like
start and then we reached out to rumble
and they were pretty good to us so we're
like this feels different over there
there's something about being able to
just
flow without censoring yourself and
that's part of the reason why I'm
talking about Tim nowadays you know
because I I found myself censoring
myself to defend him
you know and that's like
yeah and it's also it's one thing reason
for me to do that yeah it's and it's
like it's one thing if you're just gonna
[ __ ] obsess over and it's gonna be
like all your content then it's like all
right dude you know relax but you just
never mention anything it also just so
weird when people are like oh it's fun
it's whatever no but come on man at
least say something you know like where
should I be doing this show together for
a very long time and if for one day
merch wasn't here and I never addressed
it people would be like what would be
speculating like crazy like what is
going on like at least that one day I
wasn't here I just moved and Royce was
like look we're doing a show with
producers say it's just me like it's
he's moving he's trying to get his
[ __ ] internet on like he just moved
like give him a day so you know but if
you just didn't acknowledge it people be
like oh [ __ ] they kicked him off the
show and honestly my opinion and this is
just me and it's not because it's my
favorite off the show your new set is
way cooler
oh yeah I know thank you no I'm being
serious like that I I do I do love I do
love that that look is just so much it
doesn't look like a generic podcast set
you understand what I mean because a lot
a lot of a lot of like there's a lot of
shows I don't know if you I'm sure
you've seen it but like at the LA
podcasting scene is basically turned
into a cam horse thing where they just
have warehouses they do they have
warehouses of different podcasting
Studios where they just pop people in
and it's like Mike Rowe was talking
about action I think with Theo Von
talking about how like
something about podcasting still needs
to be a little punk rock and I kind of
agree with that where it needs to be a
little
you need to separate yourself from the
mainstream and I think that's that's
that's a that's a big thing I have one
concern it's a little bit of a minor
criticism it's constructive though not
enough product placement on there you
don't look like enough of a [ __ ] we
need some g-fuel up there oh yeah we
need some Black Rifle coffee up there
this is my Critter coffee mug there you
go nice my own coffee company I saw my
mom designed this logo and this is an
American mug made in America I don't
have products because it's so damn hard
to find something made in America and I
don't like
supporting you know
labor and [ __ ] from overseas that's
literally like you don't want you you
don't you know why your products made by
12 year old Chinese kids yeah no no the
quality is like the most wholesome [ __ ]
I've ever heard I've got my own coffee
company my mom roasts coffee beans
you're like okay well damn that sounds
amazing
after you order it damn she calls you
sugar when she hands it it's wonderful
experience but that's awesome I don't
think they bring it to the house brewed
I don't know how it works but that is
that is actually that that is cool
there's a lot of people that are kind of
like doing that that's that's the other
punk rock thing I do talk about when it
you know it's kind of a cringe way to
see it but when I'm talking about even
the advertisers we get like we're not
getting JP Morgan you know what I mean
we're getting you know other companies
and usually the cool thing about
podcasting I find is you're usually
supporting like family-owned companies
are owned by one person and it's not
like brought to you this don't [ __ ]
check out a check out Adam's next
segment called the Pfizer files brought
to you by Pfizer we're going to tell you
why these drugs are so great no that
would be great looking like Cole Barry
do a little musical number yeah who's
your favorite late night talk host
oh man
um Greg Gutfeld
Greg couple needs a studio audience Greg
gulfo goes a little Boomer sometimes
Nick or cater yeah okay nickel crater's
our boy we like we love Mercator he's
our boy so he's uh yeah anytime he's
been to Florida I always meet up with
him and he's he's a good idea man that's
that's who I watched late night I don't
I don't watch any of the the main media
guys like [ __ ] all that [ __ ] dude he
pissed a lot a lot of people off with
Rittenhouse and then the Amber Heard
stuff like there was legit networks
being like he's bleaching off of the
like only we should be able to cover
this public domain footage like it was
insane how they were trying to learn
crime anymore oh man that he was just
pulling numbers but he was like it's
like yeah if you guys just do an honest
show with honest people and everybody's
having a good time who knew who would
watch the [ __ ] show but if you guys
are just gonna be stiff boring and woke
people like ah socks and like Nick
Bridge like to your point earlier Nick
brings in people he doesn't [ __ ]
agree with and he argues with but it's
like they have a good time and people go
okay cool this is what a show used to
sound like people with different varying
opinions and going no I disagree and
then you know making fun of [ __ ] and
still having fun and it's yeah he does a
good show man I like Nick I like when he
gets a little when he starts getting a
little sloppy towards oh sloppy Nick's
the best [ __ ] are you kidding yeah when
he's trying to get through the super
chess but that you know when he's
reading unbreaded yeah yeah but it's
great because it reminds me of like
Johnny Carson because he was another one
that's known to do a little bit of the
sauce when he was doing the show it's
true he was he drank a lot at make Ed
McMahon is so many scenes you go look at
him I was gonna say you watch rakeda an
hour four he's more like an Ed McMahon
yeah
so okay we always entertaining we're
like [ __ ] all over the place sorry
sorry no it's okay so I want to get to
this so DeSantis just I don't know if
you saw desantis's reply they asked him
finally and it was in my opinion the
term isn't maybe this is why Trump is
pissed presidential in reply
um it was freezing it was presidential
he didn't
actively take a shot at Trump he kept
saying corporate media and all these
people but my favorite part was he did
the scoreboard and that was not giving
me laugh
so what do you do just look at the the
numbers
Trump's like that mother
sorry sorry [ __ ] I like PR I like
Republic kids that win by so much they
can't cheat
well damn to be honest you know DeSantis
won by 20 points yeah if 19.5 if he hold
on hold on he also to come oh I can't
say he because Florida as a whole has
completely redone their entire election
system yes to get rid of uh fraud you
know and it worked and one day we had it
clearly it worked yeah yeah I just think
Trump hurts some people this this time
around and I don't know Oz and then like
the brand got kind of cheap and it was
kind of like the NWO back in the day in
WCW and they started letting like you
know just everybody both Bagwell was in
it and like you know they just started
adding Vincent all right well now it's
uh you have Scott Norton in the NWO now
so like he had some real like JD Vance
and like Trump had a Cool brand and then
it was like no also Dr Oz and a Hershel
Walker and it was like really cheap in
the brand and DeSantis DeSantis kept
kind of an arms lying thing with Trump
and I feel like if he had more of the
Trump thing behind him he probably would
have lost two two or three points in the
polls so the fact that DeSantis is like
this Standalone dude right now and he's
like I good luck to all those guys man
but you know I'm doing my own thing over
here I think it helps but the [ __ ]
zeldon asked DeSantis to go help him
during the election he didn't ask Trump
so Trump was also bitter about that
didn't help him did it no so so what do
you think like what do you like right
now if if
who does a republican who do you think I
know you're not a republican but let's
say let's see you're in the RNC who
would you back as as your candidate if
you had to choose
um between the two of them yeah between
those two I I don't I can't imagine
anyone that's going to come in out of
you know where you know
I I don't know it's rough right I I
would probably vote Trump because I I
want
I don't want to lose Florida I think
Florida is really important
um I I would love if this was all a ploy
to try to convince people that they're
against each other and then
I mean they run together or something in
like three hours he's gonna although he
did say her I think like a couple days
ago in an interview talking about who is
running might might be so whether that's
like Marjorie Taylor green carry like or
maybe Carrie Lake now that she's
available essentially yeah let's run our
female data let's do that
um yeah who knows uh I would love it if
they just were like Trump DeSantis you
know Trump moves to freaking Jersey
whatever he's got his his place there to
make it legal because that's like the
the leftist version of like oh whoa you
think that that's even possible it's
like well you know Trump can just move
right he can he can literally move at
any moment that he wants well and I've
been I've been reading about that too
but I don't think it's one of those I
don't think it's like a big work because
only because you said it earlier I don't
think trunks ego would even allow him to
do that that's just my opinion but I and
this is the thing I don't know if I
agree we've we've said this see what you
mean though we said this on this show
as a Floridian I don't want to lose
DeSantis I'm we've said that we even
before Trump started the sanctimonious
thing I was like I know it's greedy I
understand this is a greedy thing
because we're in Florida but I'm like
I if I if I can get any extra second
that I could have him here I'll take it
and that because we're like oh you're
just simply it's like no as a Floridian
he's the first governor that wasn't in
Disney's pocket Republican or Democrat
as somebody who lives here we live in
Orlando like we're right by Disney as
somebody who lives here
Disney owned the state not not not
Central if they owned the state whatever
digs Disney said everyone bent over
backwards and when he finally goes you
know what not anymore we're [ __ ] done
you don't get your own country now you
don't get you don't get the United
States of Disney in Florida you're not
the Vatican you know you don't this is
not how this is going to work that to me
was like finally someone told these
[ __ ] to shut up and and and I like
that a lot about them the election thing
you said that's something that I think
that's underreported I'm glad you said
it he fixed the election system here it
is not the hanging chad days anymore
elections get done and it get done in in
a day we know who wins and that for me
is why
I think we get a little defensive and I
think it might be a little bit because
of also the sports Cinemas like you know
don't [ __ ] with our quarterback bro
leave us alone you know and Royce is
right man [ __ ] you Disney like he said
you're not the Vatican no matter how
many children you [ __ ] you will never
ever be the Vatican
a lot of catching up today it's very
funny yeah DeSantis really shined a
light on them and instead of trying to
Scurry away and hide they kind of
planted their ground and said oh no we
don't say gay and it was like the world
is like the [ __ ] he didn't say that
that's not what you're saying at all
like why are you why are you bringing
that into this what I think there's some
truth to your theory that they're maybe
just playing it like playing this off
because he he had to think about it
I we all made the comment when we heard
the Rhonda sanctimonious yeah and all
this other [ __ ] he's really be it's it
he's like like he's off his game he's
being real weak about this and it almost
looks like you know when you're watching
a boxing match you're like is this guy
throwing the fight he fights better than
this what is he doing so I'm wondering
if you're right maybe they are just that
would be the best outcome right like you
could have came up with a better
nickname than that he knew that wasn't
going to catch on so maybe you're right
maybe they are just kind of like we'll
talk like we don't like each other well
imagine that ticket right Donald Trump
and Rhonda Santos going
against Biden oh no I I don't think I
honestly think it ain't gonna last long
enough
but truth that's another conversation
but yeah actually do that one next but
before we do that I will agree that
because of because of the Florida
support and because of the manga
movement if they were to do that I don't
think that they would be I don't think
anybody right now even Newsom would be
able to beat that ticket I agree with
you but my only thing with that is and
now we always do something that's
frightening premise holy crap we we all
we always talk about gov Newsome's wife
right now was just speaking at the
Harvey Weinstein trial we were covering
like that's that's weird right yeah
that's weird
um but but I I think that the other
thing is we talk about Trump's ego I
don't think DeSantis wants to be a VP no
you know I don't think he wants to go to
DC I mean he you know he had that
statement of why he ran for governor
it's because he wanted to be around his
kids as they grow up and his kids are
what like eight they're very young
they're very young they're they're kids
still he's young like he he wants to he
wants to live in Florida until they're
teenagers I'm assuming so you know play
it played out governorship until Trump
can't run anymore
um because he knows that if he goes
against Trump it's going to be
them dueling each other essentially
because it's going to hurt both of them
there's no way there's an actual top
Runners you know there's no one else
that could maybe hit those the numbers
that both of those men can hit that's
been my theory I've been praying for is
that we get them for the four more years
he sits this he I'm hoping he's looking
at the Trump thing and going this is
going to be a three-ring [ __ ] circus
I don't want to be in this Jerry
Springer Show election you could do the
four years then he can go run percent he
could go walk into any senate or
congress congressional seat in this
state after he's Governor I mean he
could literally
primary any Republican and be like just
get out of the way what do you think
what is my seat now and then that's two
years you can sit around for two years
stay involved and then like all right 20
28 kids get all older now then it can be
a little different but yeah that's
that's a really good point Adam I forgot
about that that he did say that he
wanted his kids he wanted to be around
his kids when they went to school so you
do have to wonder if that who all said
that once Tom Brady and then guess what
when they asked him to put the [ __ ]
Jersey back on he put the Jersey back on
Like A Champion there's a third party
that you're not bringing into the
equation Giselle although I have worked
with her I've met her she's very nice
right uh of course I've never married to
the woman so you never know what they're
like right I mean that's right that's a
really good point I I think I think the
loveliest women in the world right now
are driving some [ __ ] crazy at
least a little bit you know what I mean
that's actually very good point the
hottest women in the world are
somebody's nightmare you said you were
gonna quit football all right well you
know one more [ __ ] year it's like
literally like 25 million dollars maybe
and by the way I just lost my shirt in
FTF I was gonna say stop right help me
out here and they lose 600 million
degrees
lost eight
eight eight a.m he lost Kanye money and
he didn't even say anything about the
Jews he just made a bad call
at least Kanye you lost really a bill
one and a half billion yeah I started
popping off about the Jews
told me to do it
oh that's a good question he needs to
get involved in a charity scam like far
that's what he needs to do it's like one
of these [ __ ] chairs Jesus Christ hey
so so what did you think of uh did you
did you watch Chappelle's monologue yeah
of course what do you think I didn't
watch SNL live no I caught it I I knew I
would catch it someone would upload it
at night eventually SNL uploaded it
which is weird I don't think we we
didn't we weren't picturing you like you
know in your pajamas like with popcorn
freshly popped at 11 25. watching the
end of the Evening News oh I've been
waiting like I figured you I watched it
on Twitter like the rest of us you know
I'm an early 80s kid so like when I was
a teenager you know or a young teen
pre-teen whatever is like late 90s SNL
was still good yeah oh yeah it was dope
we were in high school back then that
was dope era Will Ferrell remember those
those days of watch like waiting up with
the family watching SNL it was like a
thing uh but and if there was gonna be
an episode that I would watch it would
be this one because all the writers were
boycott boycotting so you know it was
probably it's a good one good well you
know it probably helped out it was
literally just Dave Chappelle and
Michael Che in that room like wow this
could be a good episode all right right
yeah SNL now is just Pete Davidson's
dating app
um it's just what it is every Star that
comes in he's like on Pete Davidson all
right my dead daughter 911 all right man
man I'm so quirky when all these broads
want to bang me I don't know butthole
eyes looks like a [ __ ] young Steve
Buscemi yeah yeah he looks like he has
Graves disease he looks like [ __ ]
young Steve Buscemi he should have
played young Steve Buscemi and Boardwalk
Empire well he can't because it's too
close to 9 11 because that's where his
dad died and he brings that up like all
the goddamn time the worst thing that
happened because 911 the two worst
things that happened in 9 11 were the
Patriot Act and Pete Davidson and that's
I mean I stand by that but but anyway
sorry we get off track because Dave
Chappelle the Dave Chappelle 15 minutes
and and I've said this might have been
funnier than some comedian's hour
special in terms of how topical it was
how funny it was and you are correct
that he helped write a lot of it because
the First skit was a Chappelle Show skit
where he introduced it which was kind of
funny and he brought Ashley Larry back I
thought all that thought was really good
but that 15 minutes was so funny and I
think that anybody that watched it just
trying to understand comedy
wouldn't have gotten mad but were you
surprised about the backlash that even
Chappelle got no not not at all uh
before I talk about the backlash just
just a little comment on sure like
Chappelle in general uh first off he's
the goat
um and yep he has such a good way of
weaving in
reality
and and flipping it on everyone no one's
safe with Chappelle which is good you
know he makes fun of white guys all the
time I don't care you know it's like do
it you know yeah it's fine gives a [ __ ]
make fun of everyone everyone like
aren't we fighting for equality should
we should we make fun of everyone that's
kind of what equality means right uh
although I think yeah that's a that's a
sham equality but that's another
conversation as well
um so I his monologue it was
it was kind of like
you know I remember Blazing Saddles oh
dude one of my favorite movies Mel Gibbs
you know Mel Brooks just you know he
broke down walls and been like yeah you
could do that and it's fine it's funny
yeah it is it's funny and it's like if
you allow it to affect you then that's a
you problem not the product or not the
words not the uh you know the comedian
especially you know because he even said
it you know and you could tell he got a
little a little sad it's like it's hard
it's hard to do this I'm sick of this
yeah it's like that sucks like one of
the best comedians alive today the Best
comedian in the live today said he he is
having a hard time doing comedy doing
his job yeah doing his job that's sad I
don't want to live in a world where
comedy is dead because someone can't
take a joke or you can't make make fun
of them yeah we need that and something
else because I think it got overshadowed
by all the you know all the anti
anything he said it was all funny it was
all topical at no point did I get to fly
but like wow he's really burying his
jute like he was just like he did like
the lottery
she wasn't showing any anger about it he
was just going look I'm in Hollywood
show me anything he's done in his entire
career that shows him hating anyone no
of course not he can't you can't and you
know what's funny is that the thing that
got overshadowed because of that stuff
was like Chappelle explaining really
smart and funny way why people liked
Trump and voted for him that got
overshadowed that whole segment when he
goes he was the first [ __ ] that
came out and goes yeah we're doing all
the [ __ ] that we said we're doing in
there and it's like that when I'm over
was when that whole thing when he said
when he had to go okay hold on a second
he told Hillary yeah you're not gonna
change it because it benefits you too
that that was a a he's a Democrat so
obviously he doesn't like Trump but he
he was honest and I think that that I
think that that's what makes him the
greatest comic is it's not about
politics it's not about anything I think
the greatest people thrive in
disagreement as we were brought up at
the beginning of the show I think that's
what makes things good I think that it's
okay to criticize your own side and I
think some people are afraid to do that
and I think true Chappelle went out
there and he was funny topical and like
you said there was not an any hate that
he's ever portrayed on any group of
people you know you know you I disagree
with some sometimes I disagree with this
is like you know really hard line black
lives matter stuff but that's fine if
you're funny I I forgive a lot if you're
a funny guy
yeah social media ruined everything I
just want to go back to the days like
you said where people can argue a little
bit uh can we can we go back to the like
uh Dennis kucinich Ron Paul era you know
we had two guys that really disagreed on
[ __ ] but actually could sit down and go
like all right well what about this I
don't know well we wouldn't be
compromise and we do this we would do
that but it wouldn't be actually won
yeah we would do that but what if one
dude really really wants to get his band
off the ground
laughs
by the way team Crigler if you haven't
if you haven't been able to tell yet it
would be casinich kasinich would be the
band guy yeah he would be
um but yeah I mean yeah I agree with
that I I think that at this point and I
wonder what you think Adam I think the
the ADL went from being something that
you still actually protect people to
being just another arm of the Democrats
at this point I don't think the ADL is
anything you could take seriously
anymore no the the Democrats have their
tendrils and nearly all facets of
society now
yeah I mean let's just I'm going to talk
about FDX tonight on my show I've been
digging in a lot about that and it's
dude the more you dig into fftx have you
guys been oh we we did some uh what I
could say would be expert analysis
yesterday yeah well so wow so it was
basically us making fun of how weird
that Caroline girl looks like she looks
like a weird Turtle person this is a
child this is a childish show you'll get
a you'll get a little dose of red pills
every once in a while people will go wow
I didn't hear about this story but we're
not really going to give you the info
we're like there's all we're gonna talk
about Mitch McConnell's long-lost
daughter yes oh my God she's a little
turtle person she really is the turtle
from Rocco's Modern Life filbert filbert
filbert yes but but so did you have yeah
I do want to hear your stuff on the FTX
scene because I really I was saying on
the show like I really try to understand
like I went out there and really read
stuff and looked at stuff and it just
kind of seems like a money laundering
scheme yeah absolutely well money
laundering slash controls yeah
because I I found this
um last night I was just rooting through
some of the stuff that they have backed
and one of the biggest things that they
have done is the [ __ ] vaccine yep and
it's like oh oh wow and then you look a
little further and then they were
actually part of the
I I don't know if I'm if I'm allowed to
say these things on YouTube bro we're
about to be offering December you can
say whatever the [ __ ] you want all right
well just like the Ivermectin study and
how they they push that down and it's
like it's horse pace and now of course
the CDC has quietly added it back onto
their list of things that you could use
to try to curb your infection it's like
oh wow okay interesting well not only
that remember when um when Roe v Wade
got overturned and then a bunch of
lefties started posting there's this
horse medicine you can take that kills
the baby and it was like similar to
Ivermectin whether it's some kind of
like anti-parasitic thing that would
kill that would terminate a pregnancy
and I'm like oh I missed that oh yeah
yeah we're back to horse medicine horse
medicine's back on the menu is what I'm
hearing right right all right okay I
just want to make sure I want to know
when you can and when you can oh to kill
a baby all right fine to possibly lower
your viral count nah [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah
and by the and by the way you don't
don't worry even worried about getting
our show hit on YouTube honestly we had
we had Alex we had Alex Jones on and and
before the show goes don't worry guys
I'm not going to get you in trouble in
like two minutes and he was like we
gotta start killing politicians I'm like
oh cool calling Matthew McConaughey he
called Matthew McConaughey a cokehead
and basically had a fat one so trust me
nothing you say will top that Insanity I
promise and if you get us popped you
know we're professional grifters we'll
just be like whoa our episode out of
curriculum was too hot for YouTube yeah
check it out exclusively on Rumble you
know we'll put an electric guitar and
Laser noises we'll get that really bad
we'll get that really corny graphic like
we'll get a screenshot of Adam but we'll
let that [ __ ] sense of Parental
Advisory thing over his mouth yeah or
like the duct tape you know oh yeah man
we're getting snow soon
I care about this place anymore [ __ ] you
too burn it down can I can I discord's
next can I say this a lot of people you
know you you're very smart I do believe
you are and I think you're you're very
you're I watched a bunch I've binge
watched a bunch of your stuff I think
your analysis are great but I think
something that people sleep on with you
is like you're a really [ __ ] funny
dude your comedy is so dry and so subtle
and it [ __ ] gets me like it's really
great so I wanted to say as as just two
dumb comedy guys you're pretty funny guy
man and and thank you and I think that
that that kind of sometimes gets lost in
the mix yeah we're just hacks yeah we're
hacks whatever dude listen I appreciate
that I mean I'm not enough of a hack to
go meet the president with a beanie but
you know I'm [ __ ] pretty good guy
well I feel like my comedy shines when I
have other people to bounce off of yeah
especially if they're uh they got their
head stuck in a beanie uh it tends to it
makes it really easy to it's like
throwing me layups all the time yeah
exactly you know being on that show it
was very easy to you know [ __ ] on Tim
and which I find funny too because after
I left the show right I I continued to
[ __ ] on Tim I would make fun of him and
people would be like oh you're so butt
hurt and I'm like
what do you mean like I've been making
fun of Tim exactly the same like this
entire time like nothing's changed but
suddenly I'm butt hurt because he fired
me it's like no I'm I I'm making fun of
him because he's it's Temple it's
everyone makes fun of me all right I've
done it in front of the guy like for
years we've done well I I gotta say for
me the most inexcusable thing he ever
did was where's beanie and his two
shirts to the White House to meet a
sitting president of the United States I
was I was fuming mad at him I'm so proud
of that too why because it's punk rock
because it's punk rock bro but they
invited me over there right I hate suits
I said I wouldn't go they said well you
can't go without being uh you know the
dress code he's like well then I'm not
going I'm wearing my you know I'm where
would I wear and you know what they let
me go it's like wow
I'm not a suit well the president that
bought a bunch of the president that
bought the one that bought a college
team McDonald's yeah man that wasn't the
biggest hurdle you've ever overcome bro
that's us Marsh actually started to
GoFundMe one day and this is true to buy
him a different colored shirt we sent
him a couple shirts and some new beanies
it's true we did because we're like come
on man at least buy a clean one he never
sold he never he never sold it but you
guys have no idea he's got like his
closet if you if you look in his closet
[Music]
yeah no I don't want to be clipped I
don't want I don't want to be clear I
won't clip this I'm not saying it if you
don't want me to clip it I won't clip it
I was just full survey because I always
do no that's fine okay listen is it is
it filled with grip tape no no it's all
the same shirt
wait like Zuckerberg right like
Zuckerberg's got all well you know many
Geniuses do that you know many Geniuses
wear the same outfit every day you know
Bill Gates
you know who else do you know who else
do homeless people that's true that's
true
I hate suits but if the president asked
us to go you and I would both be like at
least at a Men's Wearhouse
and I need this bra I need these brought
in a little bit even [ __ ] fetterman
who's a literal troll person who can't
fit in a suit off the rack Seer suit on
thank you hello good night sorry I like
how Obama I like how Obama went to
Georgia and started [ __ ] on Herschel
is like oh he can't speak he can't he
can't even articulate words and then
goes to p8 and he's like fetterman's the
future yeah
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Senator computer
box yeah I wonder yeah you sure he is
nice cool Obama you have integrity yeah
but hey man I mean we're coming up to
the end of the show here I gotta say
this was a [ __ ] blast we got to have
you on again dude what link what links
should we spam in the chat yes where
um well the Crigler show of course
YouTube and Rumble and odyssey although
I think Odyssey it's still Tim cast or
Adam Cass IRL I was uh requested to
change it that's a long story there
um wait he doesn't [ __ ] own the
letters IRL go [ __ ] yourself
I'm actually working on a video well
we'll be there bully tells my side of
the story yeah if you want I'll spread
the rumor in the ip2 community that
Tim's going around saying he invented
IRL I'm sure well for him
I'm sure he'd love that yeah
um but yeah my coffee company is the
freshest coffee that you can order uh
you order it and then it gets roasted
and sent you home some people have told
me they've gotten it within two days of
ordering to order it on Tuesday to get
it on on a Thursday and they're drinking
the freshest coffee that they've ever
tasted so we're gonna buy it now and do
a review on the show please do yeah let
me know oh yeah what you think yeah and
yeah anything not to [ __ ] buy black
Black doxing Rifle coffee oh [ __ ] that
company they tried to dox Alex Jones
because he was like mean to them I'm
like what are you doing man yeah I don't
understand why people support that
company I I tried the coffee I mean it's
okay
um
but I started a coffee company right
afterwards I was like um I'm gonna make
my own coffee and and I was I started
making coffee before all these other
people started making coffee I'm just
saying right everyone's like why is
everyone doing coffee I'm like well I've
had my coffee company up and running for
over two years so I don't know but
anyway try it out if you want if you
like coffee and you're doing an FTX div
a deep dive tonight I wouldn't say a
deep dive uh I I have strict standards
for deep Dives right that's like I I
think
a medium dive uh one of those one of
those jump-ins where you kind of like
pull your legs up as you're jumping into
the pool yeah like in the medium side
kinda once once I started looking at FTX
and really seeing like I was standing at
the edge and looking down and seeing how
deep that rabbit hole went I was like
all right I I can't jump into this I I'm
gonna just talk about what I've found so
far and talk about some of the weird
connections that I've found
so and I have Andreas exertus joining me
in Georgia Giant Slayer they're going to
be joining me as well it's going to be
great those guys join me on Monday base
staff Monday is a quarter black Garrett
formerly with Crowder show now he works
with nerdrotic uh Andreas exertus
flodzilla Darth call and Georgia Giant
Slayer they all join me and it's a lot
of fun I just started a new show with
nerdrotic okay and Court of black
Garrett on Sunday nights we talk about
ancient civilizations stuff like that
it's very exciting nerdronics cool yeah
he's a cool dude yeah I really like him
a lot and it's pretty cool to be a part
of something else uh I I love those guys
it's cool how much of the community has
kind of just accepted me as far as I I
wasn't unknown in the YouTube world in
in like this medium that I'm now in you
know I was I was a skateboarder I ran a
skate School in New York and and I was a
model for like most of my younger adult
life and it's it's uh I love where I'm
at right now so thanks for having me on
guys I appreciate it dude that you're
you know definitely have you on again
because we I feel like we like missed so
many things we couldn't talk about in
one hour so I really do appreciate you
coming on uh go hey go go check them out
tonight thank you man uh take it easy
see you later thank you very much thank
you so much man later peace everybody
later chat
he's [ __ ] great funny guy funny guy
yeah he's cool as [ __ ]
because the Tim stuff killed me man the
worst the same shirt thing I was like
yeah we kind of all guys said anyway
like I already had that idea
um on